doc ock green goblin the lizard but
where's bone saw mcgraw everyone else
seemed to show up but here's why we
didn't see these characters in
spider-man no way home
there aren't that many major mcu
characters who would make sense in
spider-man no way home iron man is dead
captain america is retired thor and
guardians of the galaxy are in space etc
but one character who could have made a
lot of sense in the movie is bruce
banner
though he hasn't been seen in the mcu
since avengers in-game the hulk is
theoretically still hanging around and
would certainly still be one of the
leading minds in the world on quantum
theory and multiverse science
bringing him in could have helped fix
the schism created by doctor strange's
spell but banner doesn't end up making
an appearance
as fun as it would have been to see the
hulk again there are a number of reasons
why he wouldn't make sense in no way
home
first of all within the context of the
story itself he wouldn't know what was
going on strange spends most of the
movie trapped in the mirror dimension he
already has a magical solution to the
problem and peter doesn't ask anyone but
his friends for help it's also possible
that mark ruffalo's schedule wouldn't
have allowed for an appearance but the
most likely reason is simply that the
film's writers didn't want to overcrowd
it with past mcu stars fortunately for
fans of the character banner is set to
return to she-hulk on disney plus the
core crux of spider-man no way home is
that the bad guys from the toby maguire
and andrew garfield movies all
characters who were just as much victims
as villains get a second chance almost
all of them died in their respective
movies but by curing their conditions
before sending them back home tom
holland's spider-man ends up saving
their lives it stands to reason then
that other characters from the previous
spider-man film franchises who died can
come back in no way home that includes
emma stone's gwen stacy who dies at the
end of the amazing spider-man 2. there
are many possible reasons why gwen
wasn't brought back including stone not
being able or willing to return to the
role also from a strictly narrative
angle it would probably have been too
much garfield's peter parker gets a
beautiful moment in no way home where he
saves mj from the same kind of fall that
killed gwen giving him a bit of peace
and closure while it obviously would
have been lovely to see him reunited
with gwen it may have shifted the
balance of garfield and maguire's roles
a bit too heavily in garfield's
direction
when the story is really still about
holland's spider-man resurrecting gwen
would have also gone against the very
message garfield's peter shares in the
film so the story is probably better off
as it stands
similar to gwyn kirsten dunst's mary
jane watson could have made a lot of
sense in no way home dr strange's spell
only summoned people who knew that peter
parker was spider-man and mj like gwen
was certainly well aware of that fact
the two get back together at the end of
spider-man 3 and mcguire's character has
a few vague lines in no way home that
suggests they're still together getting
dunst back and seeing her interact with
zendaya's mj would have been fun
but it likely didn't happen for similar
reasons as gwen too many characters
would have filled up too much of the
film's third act distracting too much
from the core arc of tom holland's
spider-man toby mcguire and andrew
garfield exist in the film primarily to
offer advice and assistance to holland
and bringing in any of their friends
family members lovers or allies could
have made the ending of the movie even
more chaotic than it already is still
it's nice to at least get a nod to
dunst's mj and hear that she and peter
work themselves out and seem to be
together in the maguire spider-man
universe
another key character from the sam raimi
spider-man movies who doesn't appear in
no way home is james franco's harry
osborn who becomes the green goblin in
spider-man 3. harry knew that his friend
peter was spider-man and while he does
die by the end of the raimi trilogy he
could have easily been brought through
by the same logic that let doc och green
goblin electro and sandman return the
multiverse crack created by doctor
strange's spell seems to have targeted
the worlds of tobey maguire and andrew
garfield's spider-man movies first but
harry isn't one of the characters to get
pulled through before the spell is
undone technically that can be explained
by just saying that the people summoned
were random and that harry simply wasn't
one of them it would have been powerful
to see him reunited with his cured
father and his former best friend but
there are several possible explanations
for why he doesn't show up the writers
may have simply wanted one and only one
villain from each prior film franco's
schedule may not have allowed for a
cameo or it's possible that disney
didn't want to bring him in due to the
numerous sexual misconduct allegations
against him
whatever the reason harry's character
gets enough recognition and no way home
and the film doesn't really suffer from
his absence
of course there are two different
versions of harry osborne who could have
been brought through the multiverse and
no way home the other one being the
harry played by dane dehaan in the
amazing spider-man and the amazing
spider-man 2. in the latter of those
films harry genetically alters himself
to avoid death by a gruesome illness one
that he believes spider-man's blood can
save him from
peter refuses to give harry his blood as
he fears the unexpected side effects it
could cause pushing harry down a dark
path that ends with him becoming the
green goblin he kills gwen in the climax
of the movie but he survives and is
imprisoned for his crimes out of all the
past spider-man movie characters
excluded from no way home dehan's harry
osborne is one of the easiest cuts to
understand
willem dafoe's green goblin also plays
the villain and it potentially would
have been too confusing to have two
versions of the same character in the
film
plus a plotline featuring de haan's
character would have made the film too
much of a sequel to the amazing
spider-man 2 as it would have forced
andrew garfield's peter to reconcile
with his love's killer all over again
all in all de haan's green goblin seems
like another smart cut
if doctor strange's spell truly could
have brought through anyone who knew
spider-man's secret identity and if the
first wave of characters summoned were
indeed all from either toby maguire's
universe or andrew garfield's it would
have made sense for sally field's aunt
may to make an appearance given that the
big emotional turn of no way home is the
tragic death of marissa tomes aunt may a
cameo from field would have created some
interesting possibilities however there
are a few reasons why it probably
wouldn't have been a good idea overall
for starters at 75 a hollywood legend
like field may well have no interest in
doing a small cameo in an mcu movie
field hasn't appeared in a movie since
2017 though she has continued to act in
various television series
secondly bringing another aunt may into
the story of no way home could have
ended up backfiring and hindering the
emotional impact of tomay's character's
death
the reasons rosemary harris's ant-may
doesn't appear in spider-man no way home
are likely the same as those for sally
feel at 94 the longtime star of stage
and screen is still doing great work
appearing in the tv series the undoing
as recently as 2020 still bringing her
back for a cameo in the mcu probably
wouldn't have been right for her or the
story i know he will find a way
to put it right
showing different versions of aunt may
in a story that hinges so heavily on the
death of marissa tomei's character would
be an incredibly difficult task to pull
off andrew garfield and toby maguire's
peter parkers work beautifully with
holland's story because they help him
accept his mistakes and resolve to do
better if either of their aunt mays were
to appear as well it would have likely
diluted the message while also splitting
attention during the film's third act it
might have been interesting to see a
version of uncle ben return from either
maguire or garfield's universes but
cliff robertson who played the character
in the raimi trilogy died in 2011 and
neither his uncle ben nor the martin
sheen version ever truly learned that
their nephew was spider-man
in the post-credits scene of venom let
there be carnage venom and eddie are
transported to the mcu through
mysterious circumstances that led many
fans to assume that venom would be one
of the villains in no way home rounding
out a true sinister six team
unfortunately for those hoping to see
tom hardy join the action he doesn't
actually appear in no way home that is
until the film's mid-credits scene which
reveals that eddie and venom were in
fact summoned by dr strange's spell but
they just spent the whole time drinking
in a bar what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop him it's a hilarious
twist but it's still a bit disappointing
that venom himself doesn't actually show
up his voice is heard but eddie doesn't
turn into the symbiote on screen and he
certainly doesn't take part in any of
the film's action scenes it would have
been exciting to see tom hardy's venom
go up against tom holland's spider-man
but it also makes sense why that didn't
happen the five main villains of the
movie all have ties to the previous
spider-man films which is essential for
the movie to tell its story of healing
and forgiveness hardy's venom wouldn't
have been known by any of the three
spider-men making him an awkward fit
however with a little bit of the
symbiote left behind in the mcu before
venom gets sucked back to his universe
there's still potential for a spider-man
and venom duel somewhere down the line
while on the topic of venom topher
grace's eddie brock is another past
spider-man character who has every
contextual reason to be summoned by dr
strange's spell but isn't brock knows
spider-man's secret identity in
spider-man 3 which means that random
chance is the only sufficient canonical
explanation for why he doesn't show up
of course outside the context of the
story itself there are plenty of reasons
why grace's venom wouldn't have been a
great pick
i like being pat
it makes me happy
for starters sony has finally created a
version of venom that lots of people
actually like because of how widely
panned grace's version of the character
was it might not have been a great move
for the studio to dilute and confuse
their current franchise with a return
from the old eddie brock also as
previously mentioned spider-man away
home intentionally pulls one villain
from each of toby maguire and andrew
garfield's films and sandman may have
simply been the more interesting choice
for narrative reasons
this last character isn't necessarily
one anybody expected to show up in
spider-man no way home but that doesn't
mean he wouldn't have been incredibly
fun to see
miles morales is a hugely popular
character and while he's currently
starring as the protagonist of sony's
animated spider-verse franchise that
doesn't preclude him from appearing in
live-action films at the same time with
so many multiverse shenanigans happening
miles could easily have made an
appearance and electro even references
him at the end of the movie the most
obvious reason why miles isn't in no way
home is that the spell dr strange casts
is specifically about peter parker not
spider-man in general
as such it wouldn't have any explicit
reason to summon miles also if the mcu
were to introduce miles morales
spider-man it would be better to do so
in a more focused way for now fans can
still enjoy his adventures in the
spectacular spider-verse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]